Barry Siegel I'm a former Los Angeles
Times national correspondent the author
of both the novels and nonfiction books
and I now direct the literary journalism
program down at UC Irvine where I'm a
professor of English well stop what is
going order here okay Tom hamburger is
an investigative reporter for the Los
Angeles Times where he has broken a
range of stories examining the influence
of corporate interests on government the
role of the White House political office
and the new strategies political port
parties deploy to win elections before
joining the times in 204 he covered
money in politics for The Wall Street
Journal and before that served as
Washington bureau chief for the
Minneapolis star-tribune Chris Hedges
next down was for nearly two decades a
foreign and war correspondent for the
New York Times the Dallas Morning News
the Christian Science Monitor and NPR
serving in such places as Latin America
Africa Middle East and the Balkans he
was a member of a team that won the 2002
appeal at surprise for explanatory
reporting for The New York Times times
his coverage of global terrorism
he received the 2002 Amnesty
International global award for human
rights journalism he is a senior fellow
at the nation Institute and also teaches
in the program for American Studies at
Princeton he's the author of three books
the most recently coming out last year
losing Moses on the freeway the Ten
Commandments in America matthew miller
matt miller is a fortune magazine
columnist a commentator for NPR's
Morning Edition the host of the public
radio program left right and center on
kcrw
and a senior fellow for American
Progress a newly launched think-tank led
by John Podesta the former White House
chief of staff fort Clinton Bill Clinton
oh you gotta start doing that his
his articles have appeared in the New
York Times Magazine The Atlantic Monthly
and many other national publications a
consultant to corporations nonprofits in
governments Miller was previously an
aide in the Clinton White House and a
management consultant with McKinsey &
Company his first book the two percent
solution fixing americans america's
problems in ways liberals and
conservatives can love was published by
public affairs in fall 203 down there at
the end is paul walleston is a peter
walleston i'm sorry it says Peter here I
just said Paul is a White House
correspondent for the Los Angeles Times
where he was written extensively on the
power of the conservative movement and
operations of the White House political
machine before joining the times in 204
he covered Florida politics and Governor
Jeb Bush for the Miami Herald and the
st. Petersburg Times and was Washington
correspondent for the Charlotte Observer
Tom and Peter together are the
co-authors of as it soon to arrive soon
to arrive new book end of June title one
party country the Republican plan for
dominance in the 21st century so a
pretty good crew here to talked about
the the future of America what I'd like
to do is just start off and invite each
of you to tell us a little bit about
what your thoughts are on that topic
from your particular perspective what
you've been working on or what you will
be working on and we'll start the
conversation hopefully we can start to
maybe get into a discussion back and
forth about them let's start thank you
thanks it's good to be here can you hear
me okay let's see how do we make this go
how's this yeah better okay let's see
that's a broad question you asked about
the is it about the future of America
the state of America let me tell you
what I've been working on with my
colleague Peter walleston our book
one-party country which is coming out at
the end of June looks at the Republican
machine that is built that has been
built over several decades and that is
enhanced dramatically we argue during
the Bush administration
and the book makes an argument still
relevant at least we believe even at a
time when it would seem mate as it seems
too many pundits and maybe to most of
you that the Democrats and seems to us
to at least on the face of it the
Democrats should have a lay down hand in
the 2006 midterm elections that are
coming up I mean the Republicans most
effective leader in Congress Tom DeLay
has been indicted and resigned they
let's say the scooter Livy hold your
applause till he had the scooter living
scooter libby indicted and resigned karl
rove not yet it not yet indicted not has
not been indicted but he's under a cloud
the the worst of all for the republicans
and for this administration it seems is
the news we read every day from iraq
which is their best-known enterprise and
is now a poster child for for
misjudgment arguably we argue the case
though that despite all of this negative
news for the republicans the democrats
do not have a laydown hand in fact the
odds are against them even in 2006 even
with these dismal poll numbers now some
of you may be thinking well the
republicans have a secret weapon i know
what it is the democrats
in fact that may be the case but our
argument in fact is that there are a
series of structural barriers if you
will
structural and strategic protections the
Republican Party has put into place some
of them may be well known to you some we
think as and as we started our project
we're not so well known to us but we
discovered them along the way there's a
list of about half a dozen of them there
protections that despite miserable poll
ratings and as in a spate of bad news
affecting at least this administration
currently protects the Republican
majorities in Congress and we think
arguably has given them a machinery
structural and strategic advantages as I
mentioned a moment ago that will keep
Republicans give the Republicans an edge
in 2006 and things may not go well for
them in 2006 but they'll be in good
position in 2008 and thereafter my
colleague and co-author Peter walleston
who's obsessed with sports metaphors
says this is the New York Yankees or the
Duke basketball team they don't win
every game they don't win every season
but they have an advantage starting out
every season let me get let me mention
just to quickly I know when and will let
someone else talk here one advantage is
the despite these poll numbers that
would suggest any proven in the 30s very
high public disapproval of both the
administration and the Republicans in
Congress is that the Congress remade the
number of competitive seats in Congress
is very low this didn't happen by
accident one of the things that we
talked about it in the book one party
country is an effort that began by Lee
Atwater in the 1980s at the Republican
National Committee to form common cause
with African American and Latino
activists around the country of course
we're leaning Democratic and the idea
was to redistricting Gresham
redistricting in a way that would elect
more republicans in the future and that
would guarantee safety and reduce the
competition in these seats our book
describes that briefly and I'll just
tell you should give you a
brief idea of what of what the idea was
what Atwater's idea was and we believe
it succeeded in the nineteen 1982 the
Civil Rights Act Voting Rights Act was
amended to encourage more minority
representatives in Congress and minority
districts many Republicans oppose this
but Lee Atwater who was at the
Republican National Committee at the
time saw an opportunity and the
opportunity was to form common cause
with Latino and black and
african-american leaders around the
country and say let's read istrict we
can increase the number of Latino and
African Americans in Congress but if we
draw it right this will concentrate
these voters who tend to who are among
them the Democratic Party's most loyal
voters concentrate them at the heart of
districts that will elect minorities and
the adjacent districts which once enjoy
which were once gerrymandered to in
enjoy support from which would once
elect Democrats more dramatically
because they drew support from these
core Democratic neighborhoods that's it
the the result would be and the result
was in fact in the election of 1992 more
minorities elected to Congress than ever
before but also in the adjacent
districts Democrats who had held those
seats were losing to Republicans for the
first time it's a reduced its a
resisting redistricting strategy I'm
having it and and we describe it better
in the book than I did just now but it's
an example of how when you look at
what's happening in this country now you
can look at the macro and say oh the
Republicans are in trouble but if you
look at the micro you see that it's very
difficult to see at the moment how the
Republicans will lose control of either
the house or the Senate let me since
we're still on your on your book let's
let Peter jump in also so yeah the
Republicans are the Yankees huh that's
the
all numbers show and and again the book
does this better than we can sitting
here but I want to give you a few
examples of areas that might be of
interest to you all it sounds like from
the applause I've been hearing in this
room and in other sessions that these
audiences are largely maybe troubled by
the idea of a republic of a long term
Republican majority but what's very
interesting about these structural
advantages is the the the way that the
party the Republican Party has
systematically built this built these
structural advantages these are not
coincidental some of them go back
decades to the creation of think tanks
in Washington such as the American
Enterprise Institute the Heritage
Foundation Cato others but others are
more recent creations of this president
and his political team Karl Rove led by
Karl Rove a few examples you know the
2004 campaign was really kind of a
culmination of many of these ideas that
they had for building this this majority
and part of what they saw is they saw
that the Democratic Party for decades
dominated politics in this country and
that was a a vestige of the New Deal and
Franklin Roosevelt so they looked at
ways to peel off and peel apart that New
Deal coalition and part of what they did
was they went after african-americans
and one of the areas that we saw done
where they did it so well in o4 was the
the use of a program in the White House
called a faith-based initiative many
Democrats opposed this program and it
was when Bush first proposed it although
in fact President Clinton and also Al
Gore had supported charitable choice and
did support the use of federal dollars
for religious charities what President
Bush did was was turned this into much
more of a political weapon and they did
what they did is they directed millions
of dollars to African American and
Latino churches that turned around and
whose pastors became supporters of the
president it was a very smart it was
outrageous to some but it was from a
political standpoint a very smart use of
a government program there's a number of
examples that we detail in in the book
one in one party country that that are
similar that show you how they used
the machinery of government and to turn
a political advantage the faith-based
initiative was actually the the that was
a story I was in a an african-american
church in Milwaukee during the campaign
and it was that experience where I
weren't when when I first came across
the faith-based initiative and and that
was part of what motivated us to write
this book
and there were other examples of them
peeling away groups that are so closely
associated with Democratic dominance one
another example and then I'll let others
talk but was the Republican efforts to
segment and go after the Jewish vote
again not a huge vote nationally but in
certain key states battleground states
Florida for example where every as we
saw in 2000 every vote can count
Michigan as well and even Ohio the
Republicans figured out that certain
kinds of Jewish of Jewish voters were
more likely to be convinced to vote
Republican Orthodox Jews even some
conservative Jews the war in Iraq Pro a
lot of single-issue pro-israel Jews
might be motivated to vote Republican
and so they went about and they found
these Jews in it and a good example was
we found in Cleveland Heights a
neighborhood of a lot of Russian
Orthodox Jews the Bush campaign went
there and they used if those of you
familiar with Orthodox Judaism they have
in every community I'm Nick foulest
which is the list of the the whole
Jewish community for purposes of social
services and babysitting and community
events they actually turned the mikveh
list into a voter database they also
convinced the local revaz to issue what
I probably shouldn't use this word but
in a sense was the thought was a
religious fatwa to to vote on Election
Day and they told not just the men but
the women to vote and the achievers had
Election Day Off so the girls could
babysit so the women could go vote and
they also held in the final days of the
campaign an entire Bush campaign rally
in Russian which was a pretty for the
people we spoke to who were there was a
pretty remarkable event and it was the
first time in their memory that a
Republican political event had been
carried out and Russian other
Russian Jews in New York City have been
at have been political players but this
was one of the first times that we
encountered kind of the tapping into
that community outside of New York City
those are a couple examples and I'm sure
we'll talk more well okay we've got
visioning the future we've got possibly
a one-party country I know that Chris
Hedges is looking down in the future is
also thinking about the growing power of
the Christian Right
in fact those in your you got in the
fall you've got another book coming out
right American fascism the Christian
Right and the war on America well tell
us what is your go-ahead that's what
I've spent the last year and a half or
so doing is traveling to Christian Right
events and interviewing people within
the movement and I I think that it's
interesting to watch the troubles within
the Republican Party which in many ways
is imploding which has been the main
vehicle for the Christian Right in their
efforts to take power there's a great
deal of dissatisfaction within the
Christian Right with the Bush
administration now a feeling or a fear
on the part of many of the leaders of
the Christian Right including Bob Jones
and others Dobson who worried that once
again they've been had that the
Republican Party has made all sorts of
promises that to them to carry out their
core agenda of course banning abortion
of putting prayer back in schools you
know some of the these sort of moral
hot-button issues that have mobilized
their base so this uneasy relationship
is fascinating to watch and it's of
course being played out and will be
played out tomorrow with the issue of
immigration the the the radical leaders
of the Christian Right are strong
supporters of bills that would
essentially expel immigrants or and make
it a federal or a felony to assist
illegal immigrants whereas the corporate
sponsors who they have made an alliance
with
and of course it's that mixture of the
Christian right and and and corporations
that define the Bush administration of
course want cheap labor they want and
that that's a really interesting
phenomena to watch so there's an uneasy
tension within the movement and and the
Christian Right of course is not
monolithic but at this I think that's a
good demonstration that neither is the
Republican Party I think that this
movement the radical Christian Right
people we call Christian
Reconstructionist or Christian
dominionists those who would like to
create a Christian state they would like
an amendment within the Constitution
that defines our country as a Christian
nation they would like to strip down the
federal government to be responsible
essentially for homeland security
defense and property rights and nothing
else
all social services would be turned over
to evangelical churches who would
administer everything from drug
rehabilitation clinics to schools with
of course the possibility of Pross
proselytizing and we see much of that
coming to play in the faith-based
initiative that Peter mentioned where we
are giving tax dollars to groups that
will not hire Jews will not hire Muslims
will not hire atheists will not hire
people who they don't define as Bible
believing Christians and and I think
that that that you know there's a kind
of huge shift within American society
that that those of us who are removed
from those pockets perhaps don't quite
understand and and glimpse with a kind
of disbelief and and I think puzzlement
you know why to those of us who believe
in rational thought who believe in
intellectual honesty who believe in
science why would you want to establish
in public school systems the teaching of
creationism I mean the writers of the
book of Genesis after all thought the
earth was flat and and I think that that
what this movement is built on is a
profound despair that has gripped
especially the working class
in this country remember there are 47
million full-time workers in the United
States who make less than $10 an hour
the levels of poverty even in California
if you look in 1980 those children in
this state who were living in poverty it
was 15.2%
it is now twenty five point one percent
and remember that that the official
death fishel level of poverty is
seventeen thousand two hundred dollars a
year for a family of four that's before
deductions and before the cost of
getting to work etc there is of course
no family that is going to exist if you
if you add into that if you factor into
that levels of near poverty probably
forty six percent of the children in
this state are in that category and this
is replicated around the country it is I
spent a lot of time in Ohio as I think
both Tom and Peter did and they can tell
you as well as I do that you get up to
places like Youngstown and these are
just absolutely devastated you know
former manufacturing centers and I think
that this movement is playing off of the
rage of tens of millions Americans in
this country have been completely
disenfranchised by the system and it's
extremely volatile they have been sucked
into a movement that is not reality
based they believe in magic they believe
that Jesus intervenes in their life on a
daily basis and can heal them and has a
plan for them and and the theology that
they embrace and promote is essentially
one of profound despair because it is
wrapped around this grim apocalyptic
vision where everything on the planet
will be destroyed everything that has
betrayed them everything that they hate
and they alone it's a kind of spiritual
Darwinism will be lifted up into heaven
and the rest of us will be in sinner but
but incinerated with horrific torment
and I think that there is a
psychological malaise or a psychological
underpinning to this belief system that
we begin we have to begin to confront if
we're going to confront the rise of this
very radical movement that has as its
goal the destruction of our open society
okay so now now we've got a one-party
country and a radical Christian right in
charge Matt what do you got for us I
know you concerned one thing you
concerned about I don't want to lead you
you can actually give us anything you
want but I know you're concerned to some
extent about the future of capitalism in
the in the country and the future of the
American model so well you teed up a lot
of things because I hope we'll get to in
conversation but let me let me give my
own spiel first I guess what I think
about the future of of the country the
first thing I do is I want to close my
eyes and just wish it's two and a half
years from now because I don't think the
real debate will start on this until the
2008 campaign I think that the the you
know while 2006 will be interesting
it'll be interesting to see you know I
am hopeful as a Democrat that Democrats
gained seats but I don't I think the
kinds of macro issues that matter in
sort of shaping the trajectory of the
country only our presidential level
issues and will only get resonance and
voice in a presidential campaign and if
we had a parliamentary system I think
this crowd would have gotten a vote of
no-confidence you know not a little bit
of a while ago and we'd have a change in
government now but we really I don't
know if others feel this way you're sort
of stuck in this situation where we
gotta wait another couple of years until
we get another presidential campaign and
can revisit some of the basic direction
that we have so that that's sort of
point one if you look at the 2008
campaign I think it's wide open in a lot
of ways I mean the Republican field is
gonna be wide open in ways it hasn't
been and I don't know how long went on
the Democratic side obviously mrs.
Clinton has a sort of presumptive lock
certainly on the donations and the
political talent and you know we can
talk about that in QA but I think the
issues there's going to be a chance to
have a real debate again in a way that
we haven't had in a long time and as we
approach that moment I guess the most
interesting thing to me right now is how
alienated most Americans feel from both
major parties even though the polls show
the Democrat the Democrats way ahead as
we head toward the midterm elections and
the Republicans as Tom said in terrible
shape you know president in the low-30s
it couldn't get worse than that there
they're not saying that they find
Democrats an appealing alternative at
all and the fastest-growing party right
now is what people who identify
themselves as no party or independence
and I think that that suggests or
reflects this kind of you know I don't
know people would articulate it this way
but that most people know that what
they're getting from the current crop in
power as well as what the Democrats are
talking about in opposition aren't equal
to the challenges that the country faces
so that's sort of the political terrain
substantively I think there's a reason
for this kind of public alienation and
sort of official confusion by both
parties which is you know not to be too
grand about it but I think we're at a an
interesting new inflection point in the
history of American capitalism we are we
are about to undergo and I think this is
true not just for the US but for the
wealthy nations more broadly
perhaps the severus test capitalism has
faced in nearly a century since the New
Deal as since the Great Depression and
the New Deal and I think no one least of
all today's capitalists have any idea of
what to do about it I see four forces at
work that are shaping where we're headed
one is everyone knows it's globalization
but the the main piece of it is the fact
that because of the the dramatic
shrinking of communications costs in the
advance of technology the ability for
jobs to be done overseas at very distant
places now it's going to affect not just
manufacturing and traditional
blue-collar jobs but increasingly jobs
that go up the income scale Alan Blinder
who was the one of the key economic
advisors to President Clinton did a big
piece in foreign affairs a month or so
ago saying that as many as 40 to 50
million jobs could be affected by this
new ability to outsource or to to to
source labor from different places in
the world and I think we have about 140
million jobs today in the American
economy so if you're talking about 40 to
50 million potentially being exposed to
risk and I don't want to be a Cassandra
or doomsayer we don't know how far that
will go but that's a different thing
than previous eras of globalization 100
years ago and a different dynamic for
both everyone's lives and for politics
a smaller group who were unskilled who
have been traditionally affected by what
can be outsourced so that's that's force
one force two is given these dynamics
you've got corporate America in a
situation where it feels a strong desire
to get out of the health care and
pension business and our our welfare
state is kind of anomalous compared to
the rest of the world and that we've
provided health care basically through
large companies and that system I would
say is really at risk not sustainable
probably was it was a historical
accident that it happened in the first
place after World War two in ways we can
talk about if you want but companies for
reasons that are not that they're evil
and big bad companies but because all
the companies they compete with around
the world don't bear as GM does fifteen
hundred dollars per car in health care
costs
Starbucks is raising Howard Schultz told
me the other day for a column it raised
the price of lattes you know from four
bucks to 425 largely because of health
care costs now that works at Starbucks
because it's got a customer base that
can afford to pay an extra quarter for a
latte and therefore subsidize nice
health care for a hundred thousand
Starbucks workers in the US but not
every company obviously can make the
math work when they're you know because
not everyone's got products where people
can pay four and a half bucks for a cup
of coffee so again the health care
system today is is putting corporations
under strain at the same time the third
force is that the aging population not
just here but in the other advanced
nations is putting tremendous stress on
public budgets so at the time the
companies feel a need to get out of some
of the health care and pension side of
things the government is about to be
totally gobbled up by health care and
pensions in ways that makes it very hard
and in fact unthinkable at current
levels of Taxation to take on many added
burdens as companies are sort of getting
out of the business of doing some of
this stuff and then finally and this is
sort of I haven't fully wrapped my mind
around this but there is the the
inequality factor and look in equality
has always been with us in capitalist
system but there's something new going
on now the levels of CEO pay in this
country are reaching levels that are so
divorced from performance and so
divorced from sort of any sort of common
sense
a sense of reality and the gap between
what happens in a very small strata at
the top and the the vast swath of
Americans many of whom are going to be
in this 40 to 50 million we're talking
about potentially being at risk it just
raises questions about the coherence of
a democracy when you've got a very thin
layer constantly doing better and more
and more folks feeling stressed it's not
just here China feels the same thing I
talked to a Chinese official the other
day asking them what's your biggest
worry about the reforms you're going
through now and his answer was not the
not the not the incredible structural
reforms they have to go to because their
banking systems a mess you know they've
got all these state-owned enterprises
they're trying to transition to an
economy that will be more productive and
they've done more in the last 10 or 15
years to bring human beings out of
poverty than at any time in human
history but his biggest worry is the
inequality between the very wealthy
coasts the Shanghai you know the coastal
area where they're millionaires and
Gucci store is opening up etc and the
the the deep rural provinces where
you've still got several hundred million
people who haven't benefited at all from
the boom the chine has been undergoing
for two decades and in many ways because
their health system is very screwed up
in the rural area they're actually worse
so inequality is sort of the last factor
and I guess all of this is going to play
stress on our sort of our current model
and it's going to force a rethinking of
our current social arrangements in
American capitalism I think the big need
is that we're gonna have to find new
ways to rebalance the risk the
capitalism inevitably brings in a
market-based system with the security
that people crave and the decent life
that a society is wealthy as ours ought
to be able to create we're gonna have to
find new models to do that that aren't
based on putting it all on corporations
aren't based on putting it necessarily
all on government in traditional ways
but finding answers that combine market
forces and public purposes in ways that
will set us on a kind of new path for
for the 21st century and we can talk
more about it I guess as we tee it up in
QA but I think somehow we're struggling
toward what I'm thinking of as a kind of
a capitalism 4.0 to be born here
the first phase being sort of in the
beginning of Industrial Age to to the
early 19th or early 20th century
sort of
industry booms and then you have lots of
excesses and Charles Dickens talking
about the dark satanic Mills Phase two
was sort of the whole period to the 20th
century where you had this forces for
equity trying to go against the forces
of of just pure markets giving us
progressive movement the New Deal the
Great Society a backlash against that
since the 70s with Reagan Thatcher etc
and now we're on the threshold of this
fourth phase where the old models aren't
going to work and we're gonna have to
find both a new politics that lets us
have this discussion and also a new form
of public policy that lets us update
these old really timeless concerns in a
way that keeps our country competitive
in a global economy I'd like to invite
you to sort of discuss each other's
ideas but let me start with one question
that maybe all of you can see might
consider if not answer do you think we
need a third party what do I mean all of
you whoever wants to grab the mic you're
all on now at the same time get
competitive well I guess I mean I'm a
Democrat but I have always been
vulnerable to third party temptation
just because I'm frustrated with with
with Democrats ability to lay out a
vision I think that's equal to what the
challenges are today I am hoping
Democrats and I hope in 2008 whether
it's mrs. Clinton or others will be
equal to that I guess I think that if it
doesn't happen this election and if the
Republicans can you continue to veer
right and Democrats end up and what I
think of as a kind of reactionary
liberalism then I think there there will
be a new kind of you know echo of a Ross
Perot style movement maybe not you know
with Perot himself obviously but I think
the US economy generates enough high net
worth Patriots to fund what it takes to
fund and it's a lot some kind of new
force that would probably be co-opted by
one of the parties because that's that's
what tends to happen in American history
Richard Hofstadter has this great line
that third parties the role of third
parties is to sting like a bee and then
die and and and it's true I mean Perot
did in 92 I thought he did a tremendous
public service they totally
changed what we did in the Clinton
ministration in the first year on the
budget because he proved that 20% of the
public would vote for somebody who was
up there with the charts and the graphs
talking about how we couldn't go on this
way being fiscally irresponsible so I
would like to see Democrats find the
right path on this but I think we may
need we may need a third force if oh
wait doesn't end up promising
I think Matt makes it makes a good point
I mean if we didn't have Eugene debb's
we would have never had the New Deal you
know what we're creating in American
society is an oligarchy I mean there is
a America in some ways is turning into a
third world nation we now live in a
country where the top 1% of the richest
people have financial wealth equal to
the combined 95 percent of the
population and if this continues the it
it's not going to have simply social
ramifications but political
ramifications as well especially as
corporate interests as Tom and Peter
through the Republican Party have
pointed out rigged the system and these
well-funded mass movements that are
really about the sanctification of rage
and exclusion and an expression of hate
at their core gain momentum and they
will gain momentum as things get worse I
mean if the housing bubble bursts if we
suffer another catastrophic terrorist
attack and having spent a year of my
life covering al-qaeda for the New York
Times there was not an intelligence
official I interviewed who didn't think
it was inevitable it was always a
question of when not if and I think we
always have to factor in that
possibility having lived through the
beginning of the suicide bombings in
Israel I've seen what happens when a
populace suddenly becomes terrified and
afraid and and we are far more coddled
than most Israelis you know that there
are many people in the administration
who have worked overtime since 9/11 to
make us afraid and nothing of course has
happened on American soil since 9/11 but
but give them the tools to work with and
I think that we could in
a very short time see a system that has
been weakened through a series of forces
the the the thing that frightens me the
most is that you know we went through a
period like this in the 1930s and and
there was a fear of flirtation by many
American capitalists with fascism
Fortune magazine and I think 1934
published a cover story on Mussolini
that lauded his ability to defame labor
unions and and free large corporations
to function but there were powerful
progressive forces in the country
especially through the labor unions
those forces are gone now
the press has been corporatized less
than 10% of American workers are
unionized and I don't see the breaks
that we had in the 1930s so that if we
enter a period of crisis which you know
we could enter a period of crisis just
on the mismanagement of the economy
alone III wonder where those third-party
forces are those progressive forces that
while they may not have assumed power
have have helped shape the social agenda
help give us things like Social Security
and I don't know where those forces are
gonna come from Tom wants to jump in
here Peter had told me that gore Vidal
was asked yesterday about the third
party than whether a third party is
necessary he said well don't we need to
have a second what do we have a second
party and that's the question I didn't
want to throw throw to Matt
self-identified Democrat here and
someone who has done in his book two
percent solution some some original
thinking and offered some new ideas you
laid out and Chris just referred a
moment ago to some serious problems that
could be facing this country we you
talked about the kind of economic
calamity we could face Matt you
mentioned healthcare outsourcing
pensions if we go down that list where
is the Democratic Party on those topics
because what I'd argue is that the
Republican Party at least can offer this
a go and answer there is we may disagree
with it but there is at least
it is at least possible for us to
describe something coherent that the
party stands for or believes or an
approach that they would provide is
there to the democrats are the democrats
able to answer and i need any of the
four Biggie's that you mentioned I guess
I think yes but first I should say I
don't think we're headed toward a
calamity like the one Chris would I
think mentioned I mean the depression
was you know twenty five percent of the
country unemployed for a long period of
time I don't think we're I don't think
we're facing something like that and I
think we know a lot better how to manage
the macro economy than we did then there
were a lot of big errors then that made
you know the stock market crash much
worse so I think that's good news
doesn't mean we're not going to have
potential trouble and in particular the
standard of living the traditional
standard of living for a lot of folks
moving up the income scale more than it
has in the past being threatened
outsourcing 50 million jobs well if it
ends up being that I said I don't want
to say that's that those are numbers
that are being bandied about that
doesn't mean it's true yet so but it's
but it's a threat I guess I think the
Democrats do have mean the Democrats
want health care I hope that mrs. Quinn
will be talking about health care for
everyone in the next election I think
Republicans know it's that it's it's
sufficiently an issue that they will be
talking about much bigger expansions of
health care with their 2008 candidates
as well even in spite of what John
McCain is doing these days I think when
he's running toward the center some time
closer to the the next campaign he'll be
aiming higher on health care and so will
some of the other some of the other
community maybe Mitt Romney right
exactly so and the Democrats want you
know decent pensions that Mike Mike Mike
quarrel with the Democrats or with the
with with folks in my party is that if
you add up the wishlist the traditional
progressive wish list of you know even
fuller prescription drugs for Medicare
than what the Republicans did a down
payment on universal health coverage a
bolstered social security system much
more investment in education for poor
kids in particular I think and in
teachers for poor kids if you add it all
up it would take taxes as a share of GDP
as a share of the size of the economy so
much higher than we've ever had in the
country and so much higher than it
you can make an argument would be good
for the economy the Democrats don't want
to face the idea that we may need to
rethink the way we do Medicare and
Social Security for this new era which I
think we do and so I don't think that I
think the Democrats values are in the
right place I think we end up in this
weird situation where a lot of folks
have to decide is it easier to teach the
Democrats economics or the Republicans
decency and I think it's and I think
that say that that should that shouldn't
have to be our only choice I guess you
know the Democrats the matter of
vulnerable on this because I'm not sure
you mentioned universal health care is
something that all the Democrats agree
on I'm not sure that's true that every
Democratic candidate agrees on universal
health care at least they're they're
afraid of being tagged with that because
the Republicans have managed to define
that in a certain way and also by the
way what Mitt Romney just did in
Massachusetts is so helpful because he's
the Republican governor there who just
passed with a Democratic legislature
with Ted Kennedy's support a plan they
would over several years they argue get
to Universal in a different way and I
have some questions about whether
that'll happen but that's an enormous
marker for the GOP and chant could
change the polls of debate sorry no no
that's okay and the other point you
mentioned how Democrats tend to support
education from better education for poor
kids that may be true but again here is
where the Republicans have found a way
to create doubt in the minds of many
people because if you look at the debate
over school vouchers that's a debate
that Republicans are supporting taxpayer
dollars for private education and most
of those programs are created in inner
cities which are populated by African
Americans and many of the people who
have benefitted at least many of the
people who the Republicans claim will
benefit or would benefit from voucher
programs are black kids and it's the
Democrats largely because of the power
of the teachers unions in that party
that have opposed vouchers so here you
have a an issue where Republicans are
able to go to the inner cities and
Republicans can go to these churches
again in part through the faith-based
initiative but other programs and they
can talk about how in fact it's
Republicans who have done more for poor
kids and that's a an area that many
Democrats are very uncomfortable I think
that's a great I think that's a great
point and one I'm sure you'll hear more
about in the new book one-party
dominance I wanted I promised her I
would plug their book at every
opportunity because it is gonna be great
but the the I agree I agree with you I
mean but I think and that's part of what
I mean when I say the Democrats can fall
into this reactionary liberalism because
I think you're totally right I mean I'm
a liberal who is Pro bigger batcher
Trials I think we should try vouchers in
some places I don't think it's a panacea
but I think it's wrong when the only
thing a democratic party can go to a
family with kids in kindergarten Latino
family in LA and or New York and say
this sit tight we've got a 10 or 15 year
reform plan I don't think that's a
sufficient answer and I think you need
if you spend any time in urban school
systems as I have you need both serious
top-down reforms and you need some kind
of from the bottom bubbling up choice or
competition that'll help shake up what
can be very calcified bureaucracies and
the teachers unions and I'm friendly
with many teachers I'm friendly with a
number of union leaders but there are
ways in which they have requirements
that I think make it impossible for
Democrats to serve their constituents
low income you know poor kids at the
expense of their biggest interest group
because the unions today send more folks
to the Democratic convention than state
of California so I think those are huge
problems and contribute to my worry that
Democrats can't ever craft some an
agenda that's going to be actually equal
to some of the problems I just you know
you mentioned the problem with the
Democrats and economics and you know the
fund the social programs would require
raising taxes but the Democrats no
longer raise the issue of the fact that
half of all tax dollars go into defense
into the military that you know we spent
sixty billion dollars on a missile
defense system that doesn't work we
spend two billion dollars to build b-2
bombers that most people in the Pentagon
don't even want and it used to be in the
old days that there would be Democratic
senators who would investigate you know
the the the this huge dumping of
American tax dollars into the Pentagon
and challenged particular defense
systems missiles and it's all gone there
is a complete acceptance on the part of
the Democratic Party as there is within
the Republican Party of everything these
these huge corporations won because
they're funding both parties and I think
that
I think that we have to address the fact
that the political system has become
hostage to these corporate interests and
and we know it because on those issues
they won't challenge it and when they
get up and tell you you know we can't
fund universal health care we can't go
in and fix inner-city public schools
because it would require paying taxes
they don't address the fact that you
know mean how much was it for a hammer
that they had to read four hundred fifty
dollars remember I mean it it but but
that's it's a small anecdotal story but
we're talking about I don't know
hundreds of millions of dollars it just
sheer waste of American taxpayers
dollars can I toss him one point to that
I I agree with you and I disagree with
you I agree with you that it is it is
incredibly wrong that during the the
biggest military buildup maybe in the
nation's history
since Bush took office when it's gone
from around 300 billion to close to five
hundred billion per year the fact that
there hasn't been investigation when you
know there's in any ramp up like that
there's enormous waste an enormous abuse
etc etc is is wrong and Democrats should
have been all over it like Harry Truman
was even during World War two when he
actually made his name as a senator and
got in the cover of Time magazine for
leading that kind of look into the
industrial military-industrial complex
even during a time of massive war in a
way that was harder than it should be
today but I have to say I think you're
wrong just in terms of the facts the
idea that we could fund what we need to
fund for a progress if progressives
think you could fund the progressive
agenda simply by cutting military
spending I believe I believe that's
factually wrong the military spending is
about five hundred billion a year the
federal budgets around 2.2 trillion now
you can't cut defense enough to fund all
of this so even if we could agree you
could trim defense you can't deal with
the aging of the baby boom and what
that's going to do to Social Security
and Medicare adding 45 or 50 million
people who are uninsured to the rolls of
the uninsured recruiting a new
generation of teachers spending a lot
more I think on subsidized wages for
low-income people which will need to do
as more folks become a risk I think you
can't do it through that alone and it's
and I just think we need to be honest
about I think I think that's exactly
right my point was that they won't even
challenge them I mean I think that's a
huge window into who controls them when
they won't even ray
the questions that should be raised on
behalf of the American public and the
deeper prop the reason that happens I
believe is because Democrats are in such
a weak position on national security and
our party's image is so bad on national
security that all talk of cutting
defense becomes the proxy during
campaigns for are you tough enough to
lead the country in an age of terror and
they are more to five and that's what
the law is the the politicians will say
privately yes we should revisit this but
unless you're Bob Kerry or somebody
who's got an impeccable military
background and even John Kerry's turned
out to be not immune to you know being
swift boated which seems you know
amazing still in retrospect Democrats
feel absolutely paralyzed in the sound
bite nature of ma of the modern
political campaign to talk about that
kind of stuff in a way that lets them be
branded soft on defense you're right
let's also be clear that they're getting
money from these people and big money
too let's let's let the audience join in
too we've got microphones on both sides
here let's let's say you get involve of
question and the answers because we've
got about 10-12 minutes to go the the
microphones both on there one thing that
I expected to come up in this discussion
but didn't was one thing that I expected
to come up here but didn't was the
nature of the tax base itself back in
the 1950s corporations paid 24% of all
federal tax revenues now it's 7% that's
a pretty dramatic decline I was
wondering especially for Matt and
Krysten people have talked about these
problems how much of these problems of
poverty the fundamental malaise that was
being discussed the disparity between
the middle class and the elites the
whole oligarchy thing how much of that
do you think could be solved if it were
possible even by restructuring the tax
base to benefit more the middle class
like was the case back several decades
ago I think that that's a huge and
important step I think as Matt pointed
out there isn't one easy solution but
certainly creating a more equitable tax
system and and you know what we've seen
since the Reagan administration but
certainly accelerated with this
administration is that you know that old
adage that whatever is good for Exxon
Mobil or Halliburton is good
America and and the rest of us be damned
and and I think that you know until we
begin to bring people into the Congress
and and into the federal government that
again are willing to stand up for the
taxpayer and stand up for the person who
isn't a corporation I mean corporations
are given the same legal rights as as
individuals you know I don't need to
spell out the whole Enron scandal but go
back and look at the savings and loans
bail bail out I mean this is just we you
know ever since the deregulation under
the Reagan years and it's only of course
accelerated under this administration
these corporations are I've essentially
have the country hostage and and they
they in a very pernicious and cynical
way I think use the Christian Right to
essentially further this agenda that is
their grassroots movement and and this
unholy alliance is what is one that's
deeply disturbing to the country but I
think taxation is a big issue just
briefly it was a second debate I nice
again I say this is a Democrat to a room
mostly of Democrats I think I don't
think returning to those levels of
corporate taxation makes economic sense
I think it's it's appealing in a
populist sense but I think corporations
are those taxes are paid by the
shareholders which are people as well as
major institutions and largely the
pension funds that all of us rely on for
our retirement and I think we'd be
better off raising taxes on things like
energy to force the kind of mean I think
gas prices should be higher and that's
I'm sure another very unpopular thing to
say and there are ways to do that and
still offset it the impact of it on
low-income people but until we have
higher gas prices for a long time we
will never change the kind of
automobiles and fuel efficiency that we
have it's just the only way and
everybody else knows that Tony Blair
came a few years ago and said it's you
know it's hard to worry about a country
who could solve a lot of its problems
with an extra buck on a gas tax you know
he also knows it's easy to say that when
you're visiting from another country and
don't understand the political dynamics
here but I would be raising taxes on
energy things we want to conserve and
actually making our companies more
competitive globally and not put them at
accident disadvantages in that way and
still try and cuts a payroll taxes on
the middle class because that's a
job-killing tax let's go yeah how much
would it cost for the American people to
buy back their Gov
every one of just caught will call that
a combo okay what I want to know is how
can we possibly ever have any kind of a
change of let's call it regime when we
can't have an honest election or do we
need a new system of voting well I don't
know if you're referring to the 2000
election or to the questions about the
voting machines or to the all of the
above weren't in the system in general I
mean that all of it you know that's
those are that's a hard question to
answer I mean the part of the reality of
the electoral college map that one of
the issues that we explore is that it
just the nature of the electoral college
map right now benefits Republicans
well
you know part of the issue in 2000 of
course many argue that Al Gore may have
made some mistake or campaign may have
made some mistakes and their their legal
approach to to that and as far as Ohio
you know that there was a lot of
controversy I'm not sure I ever saw any
proof that the that the potential
problems and voting in Ohio would have
led to a difference to a difference in
the outcome let's always remember that I
mean the electoral college is a huge
problem Gore won the popular vote by
half a million votes and addressing that
electoral college as well as the fact
that you know the the disparity in terms
of populate or representation within the
Senate where you you have huge
population senators centers like New
York State or California with two
senators and other states with very
sparse popular is restructuring in a way
that that we can more adequately express
the popular will through the electoral
process I mean there is important
electoral reform that needs to be done I
think the Electoral College you know
certainly in Europe it were sort of the
laughingstock of any democracy it
doesn't make any sense when a candidate
wins the popular vote by that much and
and isn't president it wouldn't happen
in any other democracy that I know it
was very important for the Bush campaign
to win the popular vote in 2004 so they
saw a lot of what they there's kind of
machinery that they created they went
out and they found voters where voters
had not been found before and they did
this and and I guess you could take that
two ways but they
they went out and they found they found
Republican voters in big cities and they
found as well as the rural areas and the
kind of exurban areas that traditionally
benefit benefit them so what they did
you know that the Democrats used to be
better at grassroots politics it used to
be the the the power of the Democratic
Party in the labor movement to get
voters to the polls to find them to get
to motivate them to get them out you
know what the Republicans did that
better this time so so there yes there
were a lot of allegations of
irregularities and voter fraud but the
truth of the matter is that the
Republicans did a better job in 2004
than the Democrats did in getting voters
to the polls and the Democrats can win
elections again but they're gonna have
to figure out a way to motivate voters
and get them to the polls the way the
Republicans have done and they've done
this through technology and
sophistication the likes of which the
Democrats just don't have right now just
one nanosecond on top of that just to
build on what Peter said I gave a talk
it to some policy folks and political
folks at 10 Downing Street in in London
about two months ago and one of the
things that was most suprise was
surprising but then not surprising to me
this building on what Peter says is
because of the you know they went to
school on what Clinton did back in 92
and you know there's always been a close
sort of relationship between the Blair
rights and the in the kind of Clinton
and the in the Democratic Party and but
they were because of the good relations
they have with the Bush White House
because of Iraq and Blair's positions on
Iraq they have been using that too as a
way that they're sending people over to
study the way Rove and the Republicans
do the electioneering because they think
they're so good at it and so a head of
the Democratic side on this which was
stunning to me for a second and then
makes perfect sense if you're just
trying to update your own state of the
art in terms of of winning elections you
should see the voter database the
Republicans use I mean I wish we could
see the whole database they use it it's
more impressive than probably we even
realize but you know the Democrats are
way behind on that and so when you're
talking when you're when you're
concerned about voter irregularities and
voter fraud determining the outcome of
an election you know you probably don't
want the election to be that close to
begin with let's see if we can get one
more two questions in let's go you could
comment on the role of or the
disappearance of the media in today's
political spectrum I mean you know ever
seen this ever since Dan Rather's
escapade with bushes voting records
the media's retreated from exposing a
lot of the things that you're talking
about here I mean you know the last
election we had all these orange alerts
and yellow lurks as soon as the election
was over there's no alert so the whole
thing disappeared there are so many
situations like that where I don't see
it being printed in the paper I don't
hear it on the radio I don't hear any
anybody in the media really talking
about you know all the injustice is
going on well I mean I just hope there's
a lot of frustration you know it seems
to be a theme I've heard in a lot of
sessions that no matter what the topic
is everyone wants to know why the media
is screwing this up or that up and
there's a lot of frustration but I have
to remind you that a lot of what
everyone knows about what's going wrong
has been reported in the newspapers I
mean the the Washington Post did when a
appealed surprise for exposing of the
CIA prisons and the New York Times one
of the military for the NSA stories I
mean a lot of these things are being
reported and you know that I think that
what we have I mean the media should can
and should be aggressive maybe more
aggressive
let me just add I mean I think that that
unfortunately you know especially with
these sort of revolution that's
happening within the media through the
internet and through the struggling you
know we see it every day played out in
newspapers that's even been played out
in the LA Times of course is that there
has been a kind of response on the part
of the media to placate their elite
their advertising elite so that you know
we are I think that there are huge
sections of this country who have become
virtually invisible you know it used to
be that newspapers would really cover
labor cover the inner city you know we
may see those people in a series or in
an occasional article but I think their
voices now are almost never heard and I
think that's really hurt the media a lot
I think we have become I think when they
criticize us for being elitist I think
that that that is true I think you know
as Peter pointed out the reporting
especially on the erosion of civil
liberties and the war in Iraq has gotten
better but a lot of that came out of
deep soul
searching on the part of the media that
acted as cheerleaders for the war and
and and many of the questions that
they're asking now could have been asked
before and we're not and so I think that
there's you know there's a real crisis
within within most newspapers and most
media organizations and let me just put
a plug for great newspapers like the LA
Times and The Washington Post in the New
York Times that still try and do
journalism because as far as I can tell
broadcast media or television has given
up there's you know there's virtually no
journalism done or very little anymore
I just want to follow up with one quick
point I know we're running out of time
but it's this in response to the earlier
question I think certainly that news
organizations need to be more aggressive
there has been the kind of
soul-searching that Chris talked about
after then the sort of rise of patriotic
response after 9/11 I think did produce
a too much acquiescence I guess you
might call it and not enough tough
questioning but there is also I'd argue
we can come back to this later a war on
the press a war on openness that's going
on in Washington right now and the two
cases that were just mentioned well the
NSA spying story and the reporter at
Washington Post who won the Pulitzer for
exposing CIA prisons overseas are both
having to retain huge their news
organization occurring huge legal bills
because they're concerned they are going
to be dragged into court and and
required to reveal their sources and
their sources or potential sources those
who talk to the press and allow and get
important stories like this to the
public are facing unprecedented
pressures including polygraphs the
equivalent of loyalty oaths the war on
the press is another is another topic we
should keep in mind and to add to that
point is that there's been a lot of
reporters will be submitting Freedom of
Information Act requests to try to as
Tom as a lot to try to learn what's
going on and a lot of the administration
finds a unique and clever ways to
project many of those I'm and Tom I'm on
Peter I agree if that totally I hate to
do this we're having a great
conversation I know we've got great
questions still to be answered but we
have run out of time thank you very much